I wake up every mood nespresso TV go  what I do love is when I do a race and  on the edge the whole you know the last  race for example I was dead at the end I  was pushing so hard and really enjoying  it that's what racing is all about I'm  generally pretty hardcore you know I  want I want a hard race I want to be  destroyed afterwards it doesn't matter  if certain yeah of course I want to win  but as long as you put up a good battle  and you've given a hundred and ten  percent you've left with 0 you know it's  not like oh I had a couple percent left  but I finished the race I'm like I want  to be completely depleted off the race  knowing that I gave it my all and I  didn't make you know very many mistakes  and and then I can go home proud spray  so GV